so what is emergency mobile alert
so it's an initiative provided by the
Ministry of Civil Defence and they're
going to share it with the Ministry of
Health and Fire and Emergency new
zealand and regional Sullivans offices
and what it is as those agencies will be
able to send an emergency warning of
looming disaster to almost any cell
phone in New Zealand do we need to
install any app you don't need to
install or download anything whatsoever
you don't need to go to any web sites
the system automatically generates a
message to any phone that's tuned on
it's inside the geographical area that
the warning is being sent to who sends
out the alerts so the Ministry of
Defence concede it or the regional
Sullivan's office can send it or the
Ministry of Health or fire and emergency
new zealand
so obviously the Ministry of sole
defense interested in natural disasters
like tsunami and earthquake and floods
the Ministry of Health is about major
health problems that affect humans and
foreign emergency New Zealanders about
fires be they structure fires or bush
fires
[Music]